how are you doing no no no no I by that
I meant how are we
Homo sapiens we doing as a species now
the typical way to answer that question
is this you choose some measure of human
physical well-being average longevity
average calories per day average income
overall population that sort of thing
and draw a graph of its value over time
in almost every case you get the same
result the line skitters along at a low
level for millennia
then rockets up exponentially in the
19th and 20th century or choose a
measure of consumption consumption of
energy consumption of fresh water
consumption of the world's
photosynthesis and draw a graph of its
value over time in the same way the
lines getters along at a low level for
millennia then Rockets up exponentially
in the 19th and 20th century biologists
have a word for this outbreak an
outbreak is when a population or species
exceeds the bounds of natural selection
natural selection ordinarily keeps
populations and species within roughly
defined limits pests parasites lack of
resources prevent them from expanding
too much but every now and then a
species escapes its bounds crown of
thorns starfish in the indian ocean
zebra mussels in the great lakes spruce
budworm here in canada populations
explode a hundredfold a thousand fold a
million fold so here's a fundamental
lesson from biology outbreaks in nature
don't end we'll put a couple of protozoa
into a petri dish full of nutrient go in
their natural habitat soil or water
their environment constrains them in the
petri dish they have an ocean of
breakfast and no natural enemies they
eat and reproduce even reproduce eat
reproduce until bang they hit the edge
of the petri dish at which point they
either drown in their own waste starved
from lack of resources or both the
outbreak ends always badly now from the
viewpoint of biology you and I are not
fundamentally different than the
protozoa on the petri dish
we're not special all the things that we
in our vanity think make is different
arts science technology and so forth
they don't matter where an outbreak
species we're gonna hit the edge of the
petri dish simple as that
well the obvious question is this
actually true are we in fact doomed to
hit the edge of the petri dish I'd like
to set aside this question for a moment
and ask you guys another one if we are
going to escape biology how we're gonna
do it in the year 2050 there be almost
10 billion people in the world and all
those people will want the things that
you and I want nice cars nice clothes
nice homes the odd chunk of Toblerone II
don't think of it Toblerone II for 10
billion people how we're gonna do this
how are gonna feed everybody get water
to everybody provide power to everybody
avoid the worst impacts of climate
change I'm a science journalist and I've
been asking these questions to
researchers for years and in my
experience their answers fall into two
broad categories which I call Wizards
and prophets Wizards technologies
believe that science and technology
properly applied will let us produce our
way out of our dilemmas be smart make
more they say that way everyone can win
profits will leave close to the opposite
they see the world is governed by
fundamental ecological processes with
limits that we transgressed to our peril
use less conserve they say otherwise
everybody's gonna lose wizards and
prophets have been butting their heads
together for decades but they both
believe that technology is key to a
successful future the trouble is they
envision different types of technology
and different types of futures Wizards
envision a world of glittering hyper
efficient mega cities surrounded by vast
tracts of untouched nature economies
that have transitioned from atoms to
bits D materialized capitalist societies
that no longer depend on exploiting
nature energy to wizards come from
compact with their power plants food
from low footprint farms with ultra
productive genetically modified crops
tended by robots water from high
throughput desalination plants which
means we no longer exploit rivers and
aquifer
Wizards envision all 10 million of us
packed into ultra dense with walkable
mega cities and urbanized world of
maximum human aspiration and maximum
human liberty now prophets object every
bit of this
you can't dematerialization deep it's an
industrial agriculture has already given
us massive soil erosion huge coastal
dead zones and ruin soil micro biomes
in you Wizards you are more of this and
those giant desalination plants you know
they generate equally giant files of
toxic salt that are basically impossible
to dispose of in those mega cities you
like can you name me an actually
existing mega city that really exists in
the world today it's set for possibly
Tokyo that isn't a cesspool of
corruption and inequality
instead profits pray for a world of
smaller interconnected communities
closer to the earth a more agrarian
world of maximum human connection and
reduced corporate control more people
live in the countryside in this vision
with power provided by neighborhood
scale solar and wind installations that
disappear into the background profits
don't generate water from giant
desalination plants the capture it from
rainfall and their reuse and recycle it
endlessly and the food comes from
small-scale networks of farms that focus
on trees and tubers rather than less
productive cereals like wheat and rice
above all though profits and vision
people changing their habits they don't
drive to work they take that a renewable
powered train
they don't take 30 minute hot showers
every morning they eat well you know
like Michael Pollan says real food
mostly plants not too much above all
prophets say submitting to nature's
restraints leads to a freer more
democratic healthier way of life now
wizards
guard all this is hooey they see it as a
recipe for narrowness regression in
global poverty profit style agriculture
they say only extends the human
footprint and shunts more people into
low-wage agricultural
those neighborhood run solar facilities
they sound great but they depend on a
technology that doesn't exist yet there
are fantasy and recycling water it's a
break on growth and development above
all though wizards subject to the
profits emphasis on wide scale social
engineering which they see is deeply
anti-democratic if the history of the
last two centuries was one of unbridled
growth the history of the coming few
century may well be the choice we make
as a species between these two paths
these are the arguments will be resolved
in one way or another by our children's
generation the generation that will come
into the world of ten billion number
wait
by this point biologists should be
rolling their eyes so loud you can
barely hear me speak they should be
saying all of this wizards profits it's
a pipe dream it doesn't matter which
ilusory path you think you're taking
outbreaks in nature don't end well I
mean you think the protozoa see the edge
of the petri dish approaching and say
hey guys time to change society
no they just let er rip that's what life
does and we're a part of life we'll do
the same thing deal with it well if
you're a follower of Darwin you have to
take this into consideration I mean the
basic counter argument boils down to
we're special how lame is that I mean we
can accumulate and share knowledge and
use it to guide our future what are we
actually doing this is there any
evidence they were actually using our
accumulated shared knowledge to
guarantee our long-term prosperity it's
pretty easy to say no if your wizard and
you believe that hyper productive
genetically engineered crops are key to
feeding everyone in tomorrow's world you
have to worry that 20 years of
scientists demonstrating that they are
safe to consume has failed to convince
the public to embrace this technology if
you're a prophet and you believe that
key to solving today's growing shortage
of freshwater is to stop wasting it you
have to worry that cities around the
world in rich places as well as poor
routinely lose a quarter or more of
their water to leaky and contaminated
pipes
I mean Cape Town just a little while ago
almost ran out of water Cape Town loses
a third of its water to leaky pipes this
problem has been getting worse for
decades and remarkably little has been
done about it if you're a wizard and you
think that clean abundant carbon free
nuclear power is key to fighting climate
change then you have to worry that the
public willingness to build nukes is
going down if you're a prophet and you
think that the solution to the same
problem is these neighborhood runs solar
facilities shuttling power back and
forth you have to worry that no nation
anywhere in the world has devoted
anything like the resources necessary to
develop this technology and deploy it in
the time that we need it and if you're
on either side wizard or prophet you
have to worry that despite the massive
alarm about climate change the amount of
energy generated every year from fossil
fuels has gone up by about 30 percent
since the beginning of this entry
so still think we're different than
protozoa
still think we're special actually it's
even worse than that we're not in the
streets now seriously if there's a
difference between us in the pros Oh a
difference it matters it's not just our
art in science and technology and so
forth
it's that we can yell and scream we can
go out into the streets and overtime
change the way society works we're not
doing it wizards have been arguing
literally for decades that nuclear power
is key to saving climate change
resolving climate change not saving it
sorry but the first pro-nuke march in
history occurred less than two years ago
and was dwarfed by the anti-nuke marches
of the past prophets have been arguing
again literally for decades that
conservation is key to keeping fresh
water supplies without destroying the
ecosystems that generate those fresh
water supplies but in the history of
humankind there has never been a street
full of angry protestors waving signs
about leaky pipes in fact most of the
political activity in the sphere has
been Wizards and prophets fighting each
other protesting each other rather than
recognizing that they are fundamentally
on the same side after all these people
are concerned about the same thing how
are we going to make our way in the
world of 10 bill
the first step towards generating that
necessary social movement that creating
a critical mass of getting that yelling
and screaming going seems obvious to me
Wizards and prophets trying together but
hiding to do this given the decades of
hostility one way might be this each
side agrees to accept the fundamental
premises of the other except that
nuclear power is safe in carbon free and
that uranium mines can be hideously
dirty and they're putting large volumes
of toxic waste on rickety trains and
shuttling them around the countryside is
a terrible idea to me this leaves rather
quickly to a vision of small
neighborhood scale temporary nukes
nuclear power is a bridge technology
while we develop and deploy renewables
or accept that genetically modified
crops are safe and that industrial
agriculture has caused huge
environmental problems to me
this leads rather quickly to a vision of
plant scientists devoting much more of
their attention to tree and tuber crops
which can be much less much more
productive than cereals which use much
less water than cereals and cost much
less erosion than cereals look these are
just ideas from random journalists I'm
sure there's a hundred better ones right
here in this room the main point is
wizards and profits working together
have many paths to success and success
would mean much more than mere survival
important though that is I mean if
humankind somehow survives its own
outbreak if we get food to everybody get
water to everybody get power to
everybody if you award the if we avoid
the worst of effects of climate change
if we somehow safeguard the biome it'll
be amazing you would say I think even to
a hardened cynic like me maybe we really
are special thank you
[Applause]